tu m'appelles samantha bailly et je suis
romancière et scénariste pour le cinéma
pour le manga est aussi pour les jeux
vidéo elle est toute jeune mais dispose
déjà d'une multitude de cordes à son arc
dans le monde de l'écriture
samantha bailly se définit d'ailleurs
elle même comme une offre ni dans le
milieu de l'édition qui aiment tellement
compartimenter les genres et des auteurs
une singularité qui nous vaut pour
partie d'être l'invité du club lecture
du collège en groupe il s'est
particulièrement enrichissant de montrer
aux élèves qu'on n'est pas obligé de se
limiter à des nouvelles ou un des romans
que non non on peut écrire d'autres
choses mais que par contre les
stratégies vont être différentes et
qu'il faut en être conscient on n'écrit
pas un scénario comme on écrit en commun
avec est ce que vous vous êtes inspirés
de notre expérience du coup en tant que
écrivain pour écrit depuis le début de
l'année ces élèves de la sixième à la
troisième se sont plongés dans les
romans contes ou encore mangas d'une
écrivaine encore irréel il y a plus
aujourd'hui en chair et en os devant tom
et est en fait quand j'imagine et je
pensais que c'était une fille mais plus
plus âgés je trouve qu a été vraiment un
symbole ouvertes etc et ça m'a vraiment
plu chez elle elle aime beaucoup les
jeux vidéo moi aussi
elle aime lire moi aussi et le passionné
par ce qu'elle écrit
et moi je suis passionné par ce que je
lis plus d'une heure de dialogue entre
les jeunes membres du club lecture du
collège et leurs invités des questions à
foison et au final un échange
enrichissant de parts et d'eau j'ai
l'impression que chacun sort avait
quelque chose en plus à la fin de
l'échangé pas que moi qui viens apporter
quelque chose
c'est eux aussi quand on parle de leurs
goûts des proches de ces rencontres
auteurs élèves se multiplient au fil des
éditions du salon qui dépasse désormais
de très loin le seul territoire de bojan